>> Kimberly: MANY STAFFING
CHANGES OF THE WHITE HOUSE AND
TALK MORE TO COME.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DISMISSING
SHAKE-UP RUMORS AS EXAGGERATED
FOLLOWING THE ABRUPT DISMISSAL
OF HIS SECRETARY OF STATE.
>> THEY WROTE A STORY ABOUT
STAFF CHANGES TODAY THAT WAS
VERY FALSE.
WE'VE MADE WONDERFUL CHANGES.
MIKE POMPEO IS GOING TO BE AN
INCREDIBLE SECRETARY OF STATE.
WE HAVE SOME WONDERFUL IDEAS.
I'VE GOTTEN TO KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN THE LAST YEAR.
I'VE BEEN IN WASHINGTON FOR A
LITTLE MORE THAN A YEAR.
I'VE GOTTEN TO KNOW GREAT
PEOPLE.
THERE WILL ALWAYS BE CHANGED BUT
VERY LITTLE.
IT WAS A VERY FULL STORY.
A VERY EXAGGERATED, VERY
EXAGGERATED AND FALSE STORY.
THERE WILL ALWAYS BE CHAINS AND
I THINK YOU WANT TO SEE CHANGE.
I WANT TO ALSO SEE DIFFERENT
IDEAS.
LARRY KUDLOW JUST CAME IN A
LITTLE WHILE AGO.
I THINK LARRY IS GOING TO BE
OUTSTANDING.
AS ECONOMIC ADVISOR, SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO IT.
>> Kimberly: MORE NOW WITH
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
NOT SURE WHICH REPORT THE
PRESIDENT IS REFERENCING THERE
AS A FALSE REPORT.
FOX NEWS WAS SAYING LAST NIGHT
AND EARLIER TODAY THAT THERE
WERE SOME EXPECTED STAFF CHANGES
AHEAD.
THEY MAY NUMBER BETWEEN TWO AND
FOUR, DEPENDING ON THE TIMING.
WE'VE BEEN TOLD BY SOURCES
INSIDE BUT SOME OF THESE CHANGES
WERE IMMINENT.
A COUPLE CHANGES THAT HAVE BEEN
TALKED ABOUT, AND OFF A LOT OF
CHATTER ABOUT THIS ONE.
SECRETARY OF VETERANS AFFAIR
DR. DAVID SHULKIN MAY BE REMOVED
FROM HIS POST.
WE WERE TOLD BY NUMEROUS
OFFICIALS IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
SAYING PEOPLE OUTSIDE, THAT HE
HAS LOST THE CONFIDENCE OF THE
PRESIDENT TO SOME DEGREE BASED
ON THE FINDINGS OF AN
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT AS WELL
AS THE TRAVEL WHERE HE HAD
TAXPAYERS FOOT THE BILL TO TAKE
HIS WIFE TO EUROPE.
HE LATER REIMBURSED THE TREASURY
FOR THAT.
BUT THE PRESIDENT HAS ALWAYS
MADE VETERANS AFFAIRS A REAL
PRIORITY.
IF HE'S GOT SOMEBODY IN THERE
WHO HE DOESN'T THINK IS MANAGING
IT AS WELL AS IT COULD BE
MANAGED, HE MIGHT MAKE A CHANGE.
THERE WERE RUMORS YESTERDAY THAT
RICK PERRY, SECRETARY OF ENERGY,
MIGHT BE THE REPLACEMENT.
I AM BEING TOLD BY WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS THAT THE PRESIDENT AND
RICK PERRY HAVE SAID HE IS NOT
MOVING TO THE VA.
ANOTHER MOVE THAT HAS -- NAME
THAT HAS FLOATED TO THE SURFACE,
A NAME FAMILIAR TO FOX NEWS.
PETE HEGSETH, HE IS WELL-VERSED
IN VETERANS ISSUES.
"FOX & FRIENDS" HOST, HIS NAME
IS MAKING THE ROUNDS AGAIN HERE
AT THE WHITE HOUSE, AS A
POSSIBLE REPLACEMENT FOR
SHULKIN.
A COUPLE OTHER ITEMS THAT MAY BE
IN THE OFFING SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER.
H.R. MCMASTER, NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR, HAS BEEN RUMORED TO NOT
HAVE A GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE PRESIDENT FOR A LONG TIME.
THERE'S A POSSIBILITY HE COULD
LEAVE AND THAT JOHN BOLTON,
FORMER U.S. AMBASSADOR TO THE
UNITED NATIONS, MIGHT TAKE HIS
PLACE.
SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS WAS ASKED
ABOUT STAFF CHANGES.
>> I DON'T HAVE ANY PERSONAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS BUT WE ARE LOOKING
FOR HOW WE CAN BETTER THE
SYSTEM, WHETHER IT'S THROUGH
POLICY CHANGES ARE PERSONNEL
CHANGES.
NOT JUST AT THE TOP LEVEL BUT
ACROSS THE BOARD.
WE'VE MADE A NUMBER OF CHANGES
WITHIN THE PERSONNEL HAD MADE
SURE WE ARE LOOKING AT HOW WE
CAN BEST SERVE OUR NATION'S
VETERANS.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAYING SUCH
TALK ABOUT CHANGES IS A FULL
STORY.
I AM TOLD BY SOME PEOPLE THAT HE
IS GETTING TIRED, KIMBERLY, OF
THESE DAILY STORIES OF STAFF
DEPARTURES AND THE CHAOS.
BETTER TO RIP THE BANDAGE OFF
ALL AT ONCE, GET IT OUT OF THE
WAY.
>> Kimberly: THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
DANA, LOTS OF DEVELOPMENTS.
WE'VE BEEN HEARING THE STEADY
STREAM OF INFORMATION ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT BE EXITING THE
WHITE HOUSE.
DIFFERENT PEOPLE, TO BE THE
PRESIDENT DIDN'T FILL THE
RELATIONSHIP WAS GELLING.
IT'S LIKE A BROADWAY PLAY AT
THIS POINT.
THE CAST OF CHARACTERS THAT
KEEPS DEVELOPING IN TERMS OF WHO
MIGHT BE LEAVING IN WHAT ORDER
AND WHO THE POSSIBLE CANDIDATES
AND REPLACEMENTS ARE.
FROM A COMMUNICATIONS RESPECTED,
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE WAY
THIS IS BEING HANDLED.
>> Dana: EVERY
PRESIDENT SHOULD HAVE PEOPLE
WORKING FOR HIM OR HER THEY CAN
TRUST THAT THEY HAVE CONFIDENCE
IN.
CHANGE IS NOT NECESSARILY BAD.
FROM A COMMUNICATION STANDPOINT,
THE EASIEST STORY TO COVER IN
WASHINGTON IS PERSONNEL CHANGES.
IF YOU WANT TO FORCE THE MEDIA
TO COVER YOUR ACCOMPLISHMENTS,
THEN YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
SERVE THEM VEGETABLES.
IF YOU ARE SERVING UP EVERY DAY
ANONYMOUS SOURCES ABOUT SOMEBODY
IS IN ON SOMEBODY'S OUT AND
HAVING THE PRESIDENT TALK ABOUT
IT, IT'S LIKELY THEY ARE GOING
TO EAT DESSERT FIRST.
IT'S INEVITABLE.
>> Kimberly: THERE WE GO.
GREG.
>> Greg: FEELS MORE LIKE A
BUSINESS AND LESS OF A
BUREAUCRACY BECAUSE BUREAUCRACY,
YOU CAN GET PRETTY COMFORTABLE.
BRING IN YOUR BOX OF PICTURES
AND PUT IT ON YOUR DESK.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT WITH TRUMP.
I HAVE TO ADJUST MY LENS FOR THE
LAST 18 MONTHS OF WHAT THIS
WHITE HOUSE IS LIKE.
I GUESS IN THIS TRUMP IRAQ, I
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLI
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLE
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLD
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLV
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLO
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLS
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLF
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLD
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLC
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLP
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLT
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLO
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLS
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLF
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLW
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLS
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLE
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLN
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLR
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLS
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLA
WILL TAKE STAFF CHAOS OVER STYLD
JOURNALIST.
IF THIS IS THE KIND OF NEWS WE
ARE COVERING, I DON'T MIND IT.
I WOULD RATHER HEAR ABOUT THE
STAFF CHANGES.
TO ME IT IS PART OF LIFE.
IT'S BETTER THAN SEEING ISIS
EVERY DAY.
I THINK THIS IS PROGRESS.
>> Kimberly: JESSE.
>> Jesse: YOU CALLED IT A
BROADWAY PLAY.
I PUT THE CAST INTO GROUPINGS.
YOU HAVE THE NATIONALISTS, THE
BANNONs, SESSIONS, MILLERS.
THE ESTABLISHMENT.
YOU HAVE THE LOYALISTS.
HOPE, KELLYANNE CONWAY.
IN THE BRASS, JIM MATTIS,
McMASTER.
THE FAMILY.
THE ONLY THING I CAN DERIVE FROM
THAT GROUPING IS THE FAMILY IS
NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
IN TERMS OF THE STAFF CHANGE, IT
LOOKS VERY RANDOM.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN REALLY
DERIVE THAT MUCH OF A PATTERN
THERE.
THE PATTERNS MERELY SEEMS HE'S
PUTTING IN PLACE PEOPLE THAT HE
TRUSTS IN THAT LIKE HIM.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR THEM TO
SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT'S AGENDA,
AGREE WITH IT, AND PERSONALLY
LIKE THE PRESIDENT.
WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE KIND OF DOING THEIR DUTY AND
ROLLING THEIR EYES.
THOSE LEAKS HURT THE PRESIDENT.
THEY DO HIM A VERY BIG
DISSERVICE.
HE IS CONSOLIDATING THE GROUP OF
PEOPLE AROUND HIM.
HE STILL LIKES THE DIVERSITY OF
OPINION.
THAT SERVES HIM WELL BUT AT THE
SAME TIME, HE WANTS TO HAVE
PEOPLE VOTE'S AROUND TEN THAT
AGREE WITH HIM AND LIKE HIM.
IT IS SAFE TO SAY
KELLYANNE CONWAY IS SAFE AND
STEPHEN MILLER IS SAFE AND SARAH
SANDERS WAS DOING AN EXCELLENT
JOB.
TRUMP IS ALL ABOUT CHANGE, AND I
DON'T THINK THAT'S EVER GOING TO
STOP.
>> Kimberly: YOUR LANGUAGE,
SAFE, LIKE AN EPISODE OF
"SURVIVOR."
>> Juan: WE BOTH PICKED UP ON
THE IDEA THAT YOU SAID THIS IS
LIKE A BROADWAY PLAY.
TO ME IT'S NOT THE BROADWAY PLAY
SO MUCH.
IT'S REALITY TV.
IF YOU WANT TO GET IN, YOU NEED
TO GET IN THE FOX GREEN ROOM.
APPARENTLY THAT'S THE STAGING.
>> Kimberly: SLOWED DOWN ON
THE HATE.
>> Juan: IT'S NOT HATE.
IT'S A FACT.
YOU JOURNALISTS, FAKE NEWS, NO
CHAOS HERE.
IT'S OBVIOUS TO EVERYBODY IF YOU
OPEN YOUR EYES AND TAKE A LOOK.
THREE TIMES THE AMOUNT OF CHANGE
IN OBAMA'S FIRST YEAR, TWO TIMES
THE AMOUNT OF CHANGE AND LET SAY
RONALD'S RONALD REAGAN'S FIRST
YEAR.
PEOPLE COME AND GO IN A WAY THAT
I THINK IS A LITTLE UNSETTLING.
>> Greg: I HEARD
BRIAN KILMEADE IS GOING TO BE ON
THE SUPREME COURT.
>> Juan: THE ADULTS, PEOPLE
LIKE McMASTER, AND TILLERSON
AND NOW EVEN CALLIE.
THE IDEA IS, WHO ARE THE ADULTS?
HE IS GOING TO PEOPLE WHO I